Oh
you
it was a real pleasure and a privilege
to be here today in this colloquium I
think is really understanding
achievement to have this kind of
Colossians here in the real Collier
computing saying however because the
matter they are dealing with is so
important for our world today that we
should just go on having this kind of
Colossians they the depth of knowledge
and the interesting questions that they
provoke in the in the audience are so
important in the world today that I'm
sure that every effort will be down from
every of the donations to continue dis
Colossians in the many coming years I
was privileged just last year to come
here and I couldn't sleep this year to a
part of it assisting to it because i
think is a great endeavor so my
congratulations to Professor gab to
harbor and to the local SEO for this
outstanding achievement thank you very
much I think the incredible power of
what the colloquium offers and this is
the third year that I've had an
opportunity to come the dealing with
trust from several different dimensions
the dealing with purpose and bringing
together amazing practitioners and and
academics to talk about incredibly
difficult society and business issues
and to do so with the spirit of how can
we in fact have it make a difference
both in what students learn and in what
people and companies can can understand
this is really a
incredibly nurturing environment for
ideas that have the potential to change
to change society I think it's terribly
exciting whoa when I seem unwell and
other visiting scholars at the Center
for business ethics and what they're
doing with this colloquium we're so very
proud of him and I think we need more of
these types of colloquium there more
than much much more than just academic
colloquium and we as an audience we need
to have more of these discussions and
these insights thank you mind well
you